as North Korea ratchets up the tensions
with a military display the communist
country rolled out new intercontinental
missiles and other military hardware in
a huge parade to celebrate the birthday
of that nation's late founder North
Korea has conducted several missile and
nuclear tests and there are concerns
that the new missiles could reach the
United States Ben Tracy is in the
capital Pyongyang with the latest been
good morning good morning it's a major
holiday here in North Korea today
celebrating the 105th birthday of the
country's late founder and during a
massive military parade North Korea
seems to have revealed that they have an
even bigger arsenal of weapons than we
knew the parade went on for more than
two hours as thousands of North Korean
soldiers marched in lockstep through the
city's main square while North Korea's
leader Kim Jong moon looked down from
above and then came the tanks rockets
and missiles North Korea displayed their
long-range submarine launched ballistic
missiles for the first time they are
believed to be the same type of missile
North Korea successfully launched from
land in February they use solid fuel
making them harder to detect and destroy
but perhaps more significantly South
Korea's military believes these large
missiles that came at the end of the
parade are a new type of
intercontinental ballistic missile
North Korea's goal is to build a
nuclear-tipped ballistic missile capable
of striking the United States in a
speech today at the parade a
high-ranking North Korean official
blamed the Trump administration for
heightened tensions on the Korean
Peninsula and said if attacked North
Korea will respond with all-out war
including nuclear weapons it's also
significant what did not happen today
many people were expecting that North
Korea might conducted six nuclear tests
they did not do that but the country's
Vice Minister for Foreign Affairs tells
me they will carry on with that test at
the time of their choosing
Alex and Tracey right where the action
is in Pyongyang North Korea thanks Ben